early on both teams looking for a pretty good
chance on the opposing goendale no shots on
goal as the puck is Hun it down moving in lafier
a chance and a save and tight there's a good look
this game watch this little flip to the middle
the faier always times it correctly it looked
like he tried to go against the flow and he did
have Allen moving across try to figure out it's
lower than the blocker but it's Montreal to Center
Ice gou checked at the Kings line Canadians do get
it in deep they're changing up here's Den know
in transition dropping for fiala moves in on
the backand save is made by Allen Kelly of again
threw it in front cleared Away by Montreal now
Roy from 60 feet shot wide Anderson Dolan on it
out to gabov his shot gloved and held up on to
by Allan mention the energy the creating second
youngest team in the league well Quinton bfield
has the energy so far today he's jumping Byfield
with points in nine of his last 10 games and they
win the draw to set up the man Advantage CAD
tied up along the boards and Montreal will get
a clear so Spence starting the power play with
Deno they work the perimeter up high to Spence
takes a shot save is made Doo on the loose Puck
Power Play Kings for Spence shot hit a teammate
then shot wide by CV chased down by Den sends
it down for kempe gets it back to fiala in the
middle a give and go with Kopitar fiala centers
but Byfield couldn't get a stick on it the play
was there fala again shoots saved by Allen and
a whistle Anderson Dolan grundstrom Lewis out
Mikey Anderson and dowy and here is grundstrom off
the draw the ramp around right to the blue paint
might have gone off a defender's stick so they're
trying they're trying to get in tight on cley you
kind of get that little you know goalies like
a little bit more work than that just a little
bit dubba fighting off a check feeds it across a
black score 91 Carl grundstrom with his seven one-
nothing [Music] La he clock this Carl is known
mostly for release right wrist shots snap shots
we'll see the entry right here oh it's very close
on the offside very close very close but watch
grundstrom loaded up here he just gets the weight
on the back foot and then you trigger he opens up
the puck is going so slow that it doesn't affect
his timing as the Kings come back kempe sealed
off along the wall but the Canadians can't clear
kempe to the net a shot save rebound loose still
loose and finally a whistle as Allen found it
at the top of his goal cre short-headed goal
earlier this week in Arizona battling along the
wall Puck workor free out to Spence Spence nice
move Spence shoots save up high by Allen ow
nice move by Spence kempe speeds up the right
wing Adrien kempe in the middle had it knocked
off a stick Byfield is there Byfield for Kopitar
9 seconds left turns shot Kopitar stick save but
again no shooting Lanes they're forced to put it
wide to the net dorak out with the Coffield and S
kovski as ghouly takes a shot and a pad save made
they've got Josh Anderson in the slot they've
got Coffield on the left wing side now walking
in tight for a chance save is made Monahan and the
Kings will get a clear down there's an example of
the King's new system killing penalties they
allowed that walk in from the corner by the
Kings here's Monahan quickly gaining the Kings
line for Suzuki and a mat now they'll set it
up Montreal mat drifting into the middle took
a shot sizzles wide of the net Suzuki up with
it rims it around Coffield on the right side
Cole Coffield a pass down low centered across
and Suzuki stopped by cley that's the best one
wow can be a little bit nasty down low this pass
makes it but watch the pad right to the post there
we both talk to pH shoulder on shoulder gabov and
Suzuki one- nothing LA Kings over for two on the
power play trouble with it regain move in left
side shot cev off a stick W around more and he
scores no now they score more thought it was in
the Canadians I think might have stopped playing
the they did they did Nick very quick watch what
there right now Trevor knows and maybe goes off
the Stick of the defenseman first Gallagher bumped
by Roy Puck picked up by Suzuki a pass to the
net tipped and just wide I think new hook got
a touch on it and now the puck goes over the
glass on a deflection gouie is there gy young
defenseman great looking young defenseman up but
not out Spence for Kee turning his pass across
shot save is made off England the defenseman
s kovski checked as he got to the Kings line
by Moore out now here's new hook carries in
his pass winds up in the corner centered in
front slowski a touch on it and a save made
Todd mclen sends out Anderson Dolan Lewis and
cev Canadians with Evans yonan and pizetta up
byce pressure a steal and a chance score Trevor
Lewis set up by Anderson Dolan three nothing
[Music] [Applause] La I'm not overstating this
watch here with Anderson yeah stick on cck and
then you know what you you practice this every
single day watch him backand forehand passes
aren't always perfect right and the will every
single second that the Montreal Canadians have
with the puck when Montreal gets it the kings
are right on top of them Moore over the line
to Deno for fiala back to deno in save is made
by Allen his best of the night nice little dish
behind and then as he dishes the Bucko he heads
straight to the net fala threads the needle
between the defender skates gets it back to
the no and he's denied by Allen as he tries to
go upstairs short side he sweeps away with the
left hand that reminded me of the Pierre Lu
Canadians turn it over trying to gain entry
pass missed new hook battling for it Den know to
fiala more to the net fiala with it in backhander
save made loose Puck Den know can he reach it
no that was just a bad bounce there over the
stick Coffield handing it off strubel in the
middle to Dvorak couldn't get a shot away it
was blocked now fala with one man back fala
weaving his way into the middle hands it off
right side in front of coms and they score Trevor
Moore again boy he's got magic hands around those
necks and now it's Trevor's Kings he gets
it done right here because Pala just he
waited he waited he waited now it ends up
being a bounce right Trevor get two goals
in today's game kind of the similar way off
the golender one on a wrap and one on just
a just he threw it there he just got a back
handed it there he placed it there more than
anything else [Music] but well yesterday the
Kings set a franchise record with their ninth
straight road win and here today they do
something they have never done on home I